alors la casquette c'est pas pour le
style particulièrement c'est juste qu'il
ya un drame capillaire qui se joue sous
la casquette un tandem tu sais en ce
moment c'est un peu compliqué de se
couper les cheveux je vous épargne en
fait le drame qui se joue là dessous
plus sérieusement on va parler d'une
optique d'une focale en fait que j'aime
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup et
même que si je devais en utiliser une
seule qui avait plus qu'une seule
optique que je peux utiliser de ce
serait celle-là
et cette optique et ben c'est tout
simplement le
[Musique]
et salut à tous les avis et françois
pour la chaîne explique mans encore je
suis ravie comme toujours de vous
retrouver sur cette chaîne pour une
nouvelle vidéo sur cette chaîne au monde
parle justement de vidéo de caméra
d'optique de montage de colorimétrie
tout ça et si d'ailleurs c'est quelque
chose qui vous intéresse vous pouvez
envisager d'aller cliquer sur le petit
bouton s'abonner qui se situe en dessous
de la vidéo on est bien ici un disque or
bien instagram ya plein de trucs on est
bien fatiha pas trop à réfléchir vous en
a parlé d'une focale du nos petits bref
d'un objectif que moi j'aime énormément
et qui peut se suffire à lui-même pour
plein de raisons qui a beaucoup
davantage et qui est très très très
intéressant à utiliser cette optique je
ne vous fait pas attendre plus longtemps
il s'agit tout simplement du 35 mm ici
un accord qui ouvre à f 1,8 en monture z
pour l'exercice mais il ya plein
d'autres 35 mm on va en parler après et
c'est une focale vraiment que j'apprécie
tout particulièrement
donc comme je le disais des focales de
ce type là il y en a chez tous les
autres constructeurs un canyon souvenirs
et consorts mais c'est celle ci qui va
nous intéresser c'est en se basant sur
celle là que je vais vous expliquer un
peu tous les points qui font que j'adore
j'adore cette focale là et qu'elle est
vraiment très très très utile tout petit
35 mm 35 mm d'amour qu'il est mignon il
est gentil
c'est donc parti je vous explique
pourquoi cette focale est très
intéressante en plusieurs points et on
va commencer de suite par la première
raison la première raison c'est que le
35 mm ça reste une focale on va dire
large mais surtout sans distorsion
quasiment sans distorsion en fait le
problème quand on utilise des focales
large comme le 16 mm par exemple c'est
que certes on voit beaucoup de choses
c'est très large c'est un effet très
stylé mais on peut remarquer qu'il ya
des déformations
on a des lignes droites qui deviennent
courbet on a aussi souvent le centre qui
est bombé qui est déformé quand on filme
quelqu'un au 16 mm c'est pas la focale
la plus flatteuse ça fait généralement
un peu une grosse tête un petit corps
c'est pas la focale la plus réaliste
qu'on puisse trouver le 35 mm quant à
lui permet d'avoir quand même pas mal de
contexte quand on est en train de filmer
d'avoir quelque chose de relativement
large sans avoir cet effet de distorsion
si on s'approche vraiment prêt on va
avoir
il peut très légèrement de distorsion
mais ça n'a rien à voir avec un ultra
grand-angle ça va pas vous donner un
effet de go pro on va rester sur quelque
chose quand même qu'ils restent dans le
réalisme et qui est assez plaisant à
l'oeil qui a un côté un petit peu un
petit peu cinématiques et qui est
surtout très habile et très polyvalent
ce qui nous amène au second point le 35
mm est une focale qui est très
polyvalente comme je disais juste avant
le 35 mm peut servir pour faire du
portrait il peut servir également pour
faire du plus large pour faire du
paysage la limite presque c'est pas la
focale la plus intéressante pour pour ça
mais ça reste une focale tout à fait
décente on peut faire de l'urbain aussi
on peut faire voilà tout ce genre de
choses là le 35 mm il est capable de le
faire
il va simplement falloir adapter comme
avec n'importe quel focale fixe
l'endroit le cadrage la composition si
on veut du large on ce recul si on veut
un gros plan il faut être quand même
assez près mais n'empêche qu'on peut le
faire faire un gros plan avec un 16 mm
c'est déjà un peu plus compliqué en
terme de rendu là pour le coup on revoit
le point numéro en avoir beaucoup
beaucoup des formations je suis pas en
train de dire qu'on va pouvoir faire de
l' architecture a vu 35 mm quand il ya
des gens qui sont créatifs qui doit
pouvoir y arriver très bien mais ça
reste une focale qui va être capable de
faire plein de choses d'un autre côté on
n'aura pas non plus la compression
d'arrière plan qu'on peut avoir sur un
téléobjectif
on n'est pas là dedans tu du tout mais
les images peuvent être quand même très
très très joli et surtout se prêter à
beaucoup de situations troisième point
et là c'est plus une particularité de
celui ci même si sony a sorti un
équivalent 35 mm f/1 8 qui ressemble pas
mal qui est un peu le même form factor
ce que j'aime beaucoup sur cette optique
là c'est sa légèreté et le fait qu'elle
soit une paire compact parce que ça
aussi ça rentre ligne de compte quand on
tourne pendant longtemps quand on le
boîtier dans les mains toute la journée
le fait d'avoir une optique qui va être
légère et compacte ça change la vie là
en l'occurrence la nikkor pèse 500
grammes c'est rien ça pèse rien pourtant
il ya une belle finition c'est du métal
le boîtier c'est quand même assez bien
foutu comparativement parlant le 35 mm
f/1 4 de sigma est beaucoup plus
imposant est beaucoup plus lourd au site
est une très bonne fin au chaos si tu
vois un peu plus grand mais
on est quand même sur quelque chose de
voilà au bout de la journée ça finit par
peser un petit peu corps humain celle ci
pas de problème en termes d'encombrement
autant de poids ça rentre dans le sac
comme qui rigole on peut partir avec sa
léger si on n'a pas envie de s'embêter à
prendre beaucoup de matériel est
vraiment rien pour ça c'est aussi du
bonheur
l'autre point important de cette optique
c'est son ouverture et là c'est pas
spécifique aux nikkor c'est aussi
valable sur la version sony sur la
nation sigma ce centre d optique qui
ouvre grandit pas en train de dire qu'il
faut tout le temps shooté à 1,8 ou un
gars très loin de là c'est une très
mauvaise idée de faire ça en permanence
on est bien à toi mais qui peut le plus
peut le moins et ouvrira un huit c'est
quand même hyper confort dans des
conditions de basse lumière par exemple
c'est aussi très confortable si on a
besoin d'avoir du flou d'arrière-plan si
on veut un beau bouquet si on veut faire
des belles photos ça on en parlera un
petit peu après mais ça aussi c'est très
intéressant et ça aussi ça fait qu'on
n'a pas à switcher d'optique on n'a pas
à prendre une optique pour la journée
qui va ouvrir à 2,8 à 4 parce qu'on n'a
pas forcément besoin de beaucoup plus
que ça et puis le soir de devoir changer
prendre une autre optique qui va ouvrir
un 8 1 4
là on a vraiment tout ce qui à là dessus
si on peut ouvrir à 1,8 ça veut dire
qu'on pouvait à 4 à 8 à 11 à 22 si on a
envie
bref ça ajoute encore à la polyvalence
de cette optique là le point suivant et
qui ajoute encore plus à la polyvalence
de l'autre hic c'est que le 35 mm c'est
super en vidéo c'est aussi super en
photo tout ce que j'ai dit jusqu'à
présent c'est aussi valable en photo
c'est une très bonne optique pour faire
des photos
on pourra faire du portrait surtout avec
cette grande ouverture on va pouvoir
avoir une beaucoup d'arrières plans on
va pouvoir jouer avec le bloquer comme
les images que je vous montre là qu'ils
sont en train de défiler avec lesquels
je me suis amusé vraiment avec ce 35 mm
soit sur f1 beat là aussi photo/vidéo
paysage urbain portrait tout tout tout
est 35 lignes être on peut tout faire
avec le 35 mm vraiment je n'ai pas non
plus que les autres optique ne servent à
rien bien évidemment un c'est juste s'il
y en avait une à choisir voilà parmi
toutes celles là ça serait
enfin le dernier point qui pour moi est
intéressant c'est le prix de ses
optiques là ce sont des optiques qui
sont pas non plus les optiques hyper
cher moi j'ai eu des 35 mm sigma j'ai eu
celle ci on tourne aux alentours de 800
euros c'est pas donné
on est d'accord mais dans la mesure où
on peut faire beaucoup de choses avec et
aussi peut-être se passer d'un zoom
pourquoi pas même si c'est pas du tout
le même usage
ça vaut le coup d'y réfléchir quand on
sait qu'un zoom sony par exemple 16 35 f
2,8
ça coûte 2300 euros dans la balance sa
joue cc c'est sûr que s'il faut choisir
pourquoi pas opté pour une optique de ce
type là moi je trouve que c'est un
investissement assez intéressant même si
on n'aura pas la polyvalence forcément
d'un zoom on est sur quelque chose qui
peut aller dans le plein de directions
différentes qui sera performant surtout
dans toutes ces directions et là le nid
en l'occurrence le nikon est vraiment
très très bonne qualité donc c'est
vraiment à mon avis un très bon
investissement
et voilà les amis c'est tout pour moi
aujourd'hui j'espère que cette vidéo il
vous aura plu si c'est le cas n'hésitez
pas à mettre le traditionnel coup de
blaster sur le pouce en l'air qui se
situe juste en dessous cette vidéo si ce
n'est pas déjà le cas vous pouvez
également vous abonner activer la cloche
pour être notifiée tout ça tout ça me
laisser en commentaire votre focale
préféré et m'expliquer pourquoi et le
partager avec le reste de la communauté
et puis moins chers amis je vous dis
comme d'habitude rester curieux et à
très bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo
je sais qu'il y en a qui sont restés
jusqu'à la fin pour voir si j'allais
enlever la casquette
non on est c'est un drame qui se joue là
dessous on est bien d'accord je voulais
dire au début c'est un drame vraiment
vraiment je ne vous montrerai pas ça je
ne vous montrerai pas ça c'est juste
impossible voilà si je sais que vous
êtes resté à la fin pour ça je le sais
j'ai là tu allais je le sais